what's that believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have the ability to create something
special that will change the planet so
to help you on your journey I started to
mentor me series and the goal here is to
try to hang around people who've done a
lot more than us who achieved massive
success and hopefully by hanging around
them a little bit longer some of their
mindsets their attitudes their beliefs
the way they see the world will seep in
to us to help us become the best version
of ourselves so today we're gonna learn
from Brene brown and the power of
vulnerability and emotions mentor me
burn a rule number three is my personal
favorite and I'd love to know which one
you guys liked the best
[Music]
I want to start with two questions that
I really want you to think about and the
two questions are what should I be
afraid of today and who's to blame
what should scare me and whose fault is
it to me these are the most profoundly
dangerous questions that we Center our
lives around and what they are
indicators to me what they're indicators
of is a culture of scarcity a culture of
not enough and when you think about
think about any milieu in your life
think about education what are we
supposed to be afraid of and who's to
blame politics the economy social issues
I guarantee you if you turn on the news
or open to paper today the focus would
be here's why you should be afraid and
here's whose fault it is
and it and what's interesting to me
about that it's it's not just at a
cultural level or community level that
stuff happens in my house every week
every week with my husband I talked to
him about what we should what should be
you know why we should be fearful and
whose fault it is mostly it's his but
you know if something doesn't go well at
my daughter's school then I'm like oh my
god this is this is gonna have huge
implications for our University and we
should be terrified right now that she's
not getting her stuff I know she's four
but this is still relevant it's
indicative of scarcity so let's talk
about what scarcity culture is and what
it looks like scarcity culture I think
is best understood with a simple
question of never enough and you can
fill in the blanks never good enough
safe enough certain enough perfect
enough relevant enough and perhaps I
think one of the most dangerous and
insidious messages today
is never extraordinary enough somehow in
the world we live in today an ordinary
life has become synonymous with a
meaningless life and it has huge I mean
and I've watched it happen not only as a
researcher and the qualitative
researcher so I sit across from people
and look in their eyes and I have a good
sense of what's going on in their lives
but as a university professor who's been
teaching for the last 17 years it's been
very clear to me that extraordinary
means relevant and the top one is is the
big one
for all of us personally never good
enough yeah which is shame which we all
have on occasion that sense that we're
not smart enough good enough perfectly
math loved enough promoted enough or not
enough so what we do in response to
scarcity culture I think all of us
everyday is this we wake up in the
morning and we armor up and we we put it
on and we say I'm gonna go out in the
world I'm basically just gonna kick some
ass I'm not gonna let anyone see Who I
am
and in doing so I can protect myself
against the things that hurt the most
judgment criticism fear blame ridicule
I'm gonna armor up and I'm gonna be safe
and we rationalize and we convinced
ourselves that this armor is really
smart and we use a lot of different
things - armor - perfectionism
intellectualizing but if you get really
really clear about what we're doing
every morning when we wake up and decide
to armor it's this simple this is what
we're protecting we're protecting being
hurt for a very simple reason that no
one really wants to talk about which is
this love belonging irreducible needs of
men women and children in the absence of
love and belonging
there is always suffering
and so what we believe is that we can
protect our sense of being lovable and
being acceptable and being worth
connection with Armour here's the very
worst news from my research the news
that above all other I did not want to
hear is simply this and I don't even
want to say it to you cuz I think it's
mean to say it but it's so true and it's
simply our capacity for wholeheartedness
can never be greater than our
willingness to be broken hearted which
is a terrible thing but a truthful thing
that we can only love and be loved as
much as we are willing to have our heart
broken and so when we move through the
world like this in with our partners
with our children with our friends in
classrooms with the people who work for
us with the people we work for there are
tremendous casualties the biggest myth
about vulnerability is that it's
weakness I think a lot of people were
raised to believe that it was modeled I
think certainly in our culture we see
that a lot that to be vulnerable to be
open to be exposed is to be weak and the
truth is you know what I found in my
research is that vulnerability is not
weakness in fact I would argue that it's
our greatest measure of courage when we
went out and asked people what is
vulnerability we heard things like
vulnerability is the first date after my
divorce
vulnerability is starting my own company
vulnerability is taking responsibility
for something that went wrong at work
vulnerability is sitting with my wife
who has stage three breast cancer making
plans for our young kids vulnerability
is taking my business public you know
the definition I use in my work of
vulnerability is simply uncertainty risk
and emotional exposure vulnerability is
about the willingness to show up and to
be seen even when there are no
guarantees
and it's interesting to me I mean one of
the things that I thought was really
interesting I gave a talk it's probably
a couple years now and it was being
translated by people doing American sign
language and they came up before the
talk started they said are there any
words that you're going to use a lot in
your talk that we should you know know
about that are might be different I said
well I use the word vulnerability a lot
and they kind of there were two of them
they kind of looked each other they said
oh we do this for vulnerability and I
said what does that mean they said it
means weak in the knees and I'm like wow
that's not how I talk about
vulnerability and she said well there's
only one other sign for vulnerability
and I said what is it and she said and I
said oh that's what I'm talking about
and so to me vulnerability is our most
accurate measure of courage I mean it's
pretty powerful when I have 13,000
pieces of data collected over 12 years
that I cannot find a single incident or
story of courage that was not completely
underpinned by vulnerability I think the
problem arises that if there are so many
little paradoxes with vulnerability and
one of them is that vulnerability is
courage in you but weakness in me when I
meet you it's the first thing I look for
in you but it's the last thing I want to
show you and me and so I think to really
put ourselves out there knowing that if
we do that enough we're going to fail I
just don't think it gets more courageous
than that
if i roughly took the people I
interviewed and divided them into people
who really have a sense of worthiness
that's what this comes down to a sense
of worthiness they have a sense a strong
sense of love and belonging and folks
who struggle for it and folks who are
always wondering if they're good enough
there was only one variable that
separated the people who have a strong
sense of love and belonging and have a
strong and really struggle for it and
that was the people who have a strong
sense of love and belonging believe
they're worthy of love and belonging
it's it they believe they're worthy
and to me the hard part of the one thing
that keeps us out of connection is our
fear that we're not worthy of connection
was something that personally and
professionally I felt like I needed to
understand better so what I did is I
took all of the interviews where I saw
worthiness where I saw people living
that way and just looked at those what
do these people have in common and I
have I have a slight office-supply
addiction but it's another talk so I had
a manila notebook a new manila folder
and I had a sharpie and I was like what
am I gonna call this research and the
first words that came to my mind were
wholehearted these are kind of
wholehearted people living from this
deep sense of worthiness so I wrote at
the top of the manila folder and I
started looking at the data in fact I
did it first in this very full in a Ford
a very intensive data analysis where I
went back pulled these interviews pulled
the stories pulled the incidents what's
the what's the theme what's the pattern
my husband left town with the kids
because I always go into this kind of
Jackson Pollock crazy thing where I'm
just like writing and going and kind of
just in my researcher mode and so here's
what I found what they had in common was
a sense of courage and I want to I want
to I want to separate courage and
bravery for you for a minute
courage the original definition of
courage when it first came into the
English language it's from the latin
word cur meaning heart and the original
definition was to tell the story of who
you are with your whole heart and so
these folks had very simply the courage
to be imperfect they had the compassion
to be kind to themselves first and then
to others
because as it turns out we can't
practice compassion with other people if
we can't treat ourselves kindly and the
last was they had connection and this
was the hard part
as a result of authenticity they were
willing to let go of who they thought
they should be in order to be who they
were which is you have to absolutely do
that for connection
the other thing that they had in common
was this they fully embraced
vulnerability they believed that what
made them vulnerable made them beautiful
they didn't talk about vulnerability
being comfortable nor did they really
talked about it being excruciating as I
had heard earlier in the shame
interviewing they just talked about it
being necessary they talked about the
willingness to say I love you first the
willingness to do something where there
are no guarantees the willingness to
breathe through waiting for the doctor
to call after your mammogram they're
willing to invest in a relationship that
may or may not work out they thought
this was fundamental let me tell you
this real story this just happened I
spoke at HubSpot last week okay
thirteen thousand people in this Boston
Convention Center it's like ten minutes
before I go on and I'm making that I
look at Twitter and I'm this person
since this tweet out that says why is
Brene at HubSpot why is at Brene brown
at HubSpot 2015 and he just tweeted like
love seth godin love amy schumer all
these people but why is burn a brown I'm
like oh my god
why am i at HubSpot what am i doing here
and then I'm like I start sweating and
it's like any of its a convention
centers like because you ladies you know
I'm like oh my god what am i doing and
I'm the opening keynote and I'm like and
then he tweets it again and I'm like oh
my god and so like these are marketing
people I don't know anything so I start
googling in my phone
marketing terms 2015 the first time that
comes up is incentivize I'm like I've
got to work that well I've got to work
the word incentivize into this this
keynote I'm like what does that mean
exactly I don't know but I'm gonna say
we're gonna incentivize I'm like what is
happening and I have a total crisis of
confidence like because you know shame
drives to tapes not good enough and who
do you think you are and like
whoo-hoo am I right stops terrible and
so then all of a sudden I'm like who is
it because what happens when you get
backed into a corner my brain is making
up the story you don't belong here I'm
like that story's not gonna work cuz I'm
going on in five seconds I'm like so I'm
like okay
the best-case scenario attack attack
attack this guy maybe attack him from
the stage maybe use that as my opening
maybe say like John Doe asks what I'm
doing here well let me tell y'all you
know and then I click on the tweet to
figure out what his name is and I
accidentally hit the link in his tweet
and it goes to this page that says what
does Bernie Browns doing you're HubSpot
she's talking about vulnerability and
that's so important
here's her TED talk here could you
imagine if I would have gone out there
and been like a crate no and that's a
true story
it just happened because what happens is
when something hard happens and we're
captured by something difficult our
emotions get the first crack at making
sense of something bad look a hard phone
call a disagreement at work we think
that we're rational beings we think that
cognition is going to carry us through
and make sense of it but it doesn't you
know emotions driving thought and
behavior are not even in the front seat
riding shotgun they're not even the back
seat thought and behavior and the trunk
going hey and emotions driving so the
first thing we do is we tell ourselves a
story that reduces ambiguity about what
happened so oh I'm not supposed to be
here I'm not good enough to be here men
and women who have the greatest capacity
for rising strong in the moment
something happens they hack into that
neurobiological process of making up a
story they stop and say wait a minute
what's actually going on here what is
what am I feeling what do I know for
sure because what is you know what is a
story there's a name and research for a
story that has one or two limited data
points and we fill in the rest with fear
Wow
it's called a conspiracy
a conspiracy is a story with limited
data points so here's what I know I know
a guy sent a tweet I know I'm getting
ready to talk that's all I know
so now that I'm ready to ruin his career
and use him as a whipping person you
know as I stalk what is going on the
first step of rising strong is recognize
you've been snagged by emotion and get
curious about it that's it but how many
of you were raised in families were you
encouraged to get curious about your
emotions and talk about them and explore
them right versus how many of you were
raised in families where you were taught
hey suck it up yep push through and get
it done so the first thing is really
reckoning with emotion what am I feeling
and when and what do I need to know more
about that is a huge and so that thing
that you say like it just is something
that someone knows something that I
don't know do they have information I
don't have that's a huge part of the
reckoning we just don't do it
so in that minute in the backstage when
I was how on my phone I could have just
said
whoa burn a your like heart is racing
your your your teeth are clenched and
you're going in for the kill here what
do you know about this yeah nothing you
know nothing and what if you do
everything who cares tickets yeah you
know there are 13,000 people you're
gonna spend an hour targeting one guy
you don't know thank you guys so much
for watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love
to know what did you learn from this
video that you're going to immediately
apply somehow to your life or your
business what was the single most
important lesson that you learned leave
it down in the comments below I'm really
curious to find out I also want to give
a quick shout out to Mike Markham Mike
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word and doing the
review on restaurant HR I really really
really appreciate the support Mike and
I'm so glad that you enjoyed my book so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
[Music]